secretary blinken uh tony welcome back
to nato headquarters it's always a great
pleasure to welcome you
and let me start by thanking you for
everything you do uh
the continued significant support to
ukraine
the
sanctions the heavy costs we are
imposing on
russia and the russian war machine
and also
the strengthening our collective defense
here in europe with more u.s presence in
europe
and let me also thank you for tireless
efforts to
consult to coordinate with nato allies
and to share intelligence and
information throughout this crisis
the us leadership has been outstanding
and is indispensable
and that is of great importance when we
face a very dangerous situation with the
ongoing war in ukraine
so uh i look forward to sit down with
you with the other uh
foreign ministers uh in nato and to
discuss uh
a wide range of issues today and
tomorrow of course including
ukraine but also that we are able to sit
down with our asia-pacific partners
australia new zealand japan and south
korea and to address the global
ramifications of
the crisis in ukraine and how we are
going to work together in different
areas with our asia-pacific partners
and then of course tonight we will start
to
have a
start our meeting with a discussion uh
addressing the strategic concept
which is an important document for nato
outlining how nato should continue to be
the strongest
alliance in history uh facing a more uh
dangerous world and a new security
reality so once again welcome it's good
to have you thank you jens very much
and i was gonna say uh it's really good
to be back except i feel like we've
never left
um
in fact i'm gonna ask you if there are
apartments available at nato
headquarters because we're here so much
that uh we probably need one and that uh
actually gets to something that that jen
said that is so important
a hallmark of everything that we've been
doing
in the months leading up to russia's
aggression against ukraine and in the
time since has been our
extraordinary collaboration coordination
consultation on every element
of of the response and that's exactly
what we're continuing uh here today and
tomorrow
we set out to do three things if russia
decided to pursue this horrific
aggression against ukraine uh one was to
support our ukrainian partners we're
doing that
two was to put extraordinary pressure on
russia we're doing that
three was to
make sure that we were shoring up the
defenses of our own alliance nato and
we're doing that uh and today tomorrow
we'll continue to talk about not only
how we can sustain these efforts but how
we can build upon them
second as the secretary general said
um
we're also in a period of tremendous
importance for the future of our
alliance
not just with regard to the russian
aggression against ukraine
but more broadly going toward the nato
summit a new strategic concept that will
be very
uh much informed by what's happening now
in europe but also by other challenges
that we have to face together as an
alliance so this is an important moment
for us to come together to continue to
do the work leading up to the summit the
new student concept working with uh with
new partners all of which we'll be doing
in the
next two days finally let me say i'm yes
i'm grateful for
your kind words about american
engagement american leadership but our
expression is right back at you
we would not be where we are uh absent
your extraordinary leadership with this
alliance and i think that's evident in
the fact that allies came together
unanimously uh when our leaders met just
a couple of weeks ago and asked the
secretary general to stay on past his
term we are very very grateful that
you've agreed to do that uh we've got a
lot of work to do together and we can
continue it right now thank you thank
you
tomorrow
all right
thank you
directions
you